welcome back everybody to the h3 podcast
live today we're staying cool even
though it's hot outside we've got a top
of the week here for you guys we are
sponsored this week by Dollar Shave Club
hellofresh and of course h3h3
productions ourselves with some hot
t-shirts and of course subscribers like
you thank you everyone for supporting us
more about that later now today there's
a lot I want to get to first of all I
want to talk about the fundraising we
did on Tuesday we're currently at
$157,000 our initial goal was a hundred
thousand yeah I can't I really think we
can get that to two hundred thousand I
think so you know hurricane Steve Harvey
devastated Texas and it's kind of messed
up because these people are trying to
rebuild their lives and it's like nobody
even cares about Steve Harvey anymore
it's all about irma who's becoming
piling in on Florida and it's hard not
to think about Emma because she
apparently what do you how do you what
do you think about when you hear Irma
what kind of woman is that all Direction
lady
herma she's just at the buffet line and
she's just like piling up that plate you
just want like one like egg roll but
you're stuck buying her mama she's a cow
Jesus simmer
okay I'm just gonna kill people [ __ ]
Irma
everyone's talking about Irma who has
now become officially the most powerful
hurricane ever to come out of the
Atlantic category 5 185 miles per hour
wind I want to talk about that I want to
talk about all the Raffles we did and we
got a lot of interesting data on that
ones it's still live I'll explain all
that but before that I want to want to
talk about staying cool huh
hey staying cool Lila I'm trying I don't
know if I'm cool enough to be cool it's
just
is this really soup stupid meme that was
just tickled us we were walking out what
was it last week yeah who was Dan on the
phone with when he was talking with the
shirt company okay
so we're walking out and Dan's on the
phone with someone it was a girl too
because it was like kind of flirtatious
I felt like we're walking outside we're
done I'm gonna walk it out and dance
wrapping up a phone call with this with
one of these girls we work with and he
says all right
stay cool pretty innocent statement but
I just was like Dan it wasn't like one
of the hottest day here it was hot it
was brilliant away so it was kind of
like a joke about the weather wasn't a
joke he was earnest he was completely
serious and it's a fair you know it's a
good wish to make for somebody on a hot
day stay cold but we just started joking
internally about it and so I wanted to
bring that little story to light one
didn't bring you guys in on it so that
we can put it on a shirt and about a
week and then and another week we bury
it and it's funny again you know it's
the life cycle of a meme stay cool maybe
not that good maybe not that maybe not
that no necessary so let's have a look
over here at our fundraising here some
really interesting data first of all we
have two new justin roiland
original drawings with his signature on
them
are they on here yes one is there oh
yeah one says and whatever something
about like you get it it's Justin it's
funny it's hilarious so here I thought
this stuff was interesting I want to go
over it by the way just for the record
this is going to run until next Tuesday
it's going to a natural a national
organization directly one of the most
highest rated reputable companies out
there for for raising money for help
people mm-hmm
and you basically
all these rewards we we have here our
raffle tickets so if you put $1.00 in
you still have a chance the won if you
put a thousand you have a thousand times
more tickets one dollar equals one
raffle there's all kinds of amazing [ __ ]
here I encourage you to go check it out
but I wanted to go over some of the
stats here which I thought was real real
interesting stuff here let's have a look
so look at this this this [ __ ] is really
inspiring
twenty dollars are less donations in
total equalled 70,000 bucks and that's
crazy Wow a hundred dollars or less the
first time I'm looking at this dice oh
yeah okay so this I mean it's really
inspiring here look people who did not
want any reward at all
forty thousand five dollars or less was
twenty eight thousand and here this is
kind of inspiring to me one dollar
donations totaled $7,300 where do you
see that right here I have it
highlighted on my screen
see how freaking cool is that so all you
guys out there who participate in you
know charity streams or donations who
say one dollar doesn't make a difference
here we raise seven thousand three
hundred forty two dollars from one
dollar donations there's so many people
and so I don't know I don't know if one
of these one dollar guys is gonna win
but that'd be kind of cool it's crazy
because we when we did it we only had
like thirty thousand people watching
right so it's like every single person
donate I think everybody in that initial
stream probably contributed which is
really inspiring
you guys are awesome in that that was
such a special stream we all felt really
really honored to have been a part of
that now on for the the gifts or the
giveaways I guess so coming in first
place was the jars of Szechuan sauce by
far that alone raised fifteen thousand
five hundred forty dollars of people
wanting that sauce that's pretty awesome
and well we had one donator matt from
loot crate give leat what doesn't three
hundred thirty seven dollars and then we
had the rick and morty art book which
raised thirteen
thousand Jesus Justin
bringing home the bacon and then this
one kind of surprised me signed to vape
number three we signed to babe and I
smoked it all day - I don't know if that
was what put it up to the next level you
sick [ __ ] you weird fetish [ __ ] we all
use that oh we all used it you sickos
you're sick thank you for donating um
Teddy fresh hat the number one original
signed Teddy fresh hat it was crazy
$8,500 that's good amazing that's crazy
that's so cool alex hirsch though yeah
threw down a thousand for that he only
found out about that today I had no idea
hmm I was kind of pissed when I saw it
because like wait I gave 5,000 I wish I
bid on something because we put it in I
guess before it was final I'm like wait
alex is putting his trying to buy I
should have bought some sauce and resold
it so I can't wait to see you actually
wins
so we'll decide that on Tuesday on the
Tuesday episode coming up next week
well announced all the winners this was
freaking out riot neck Fupa if you guys
were watching that you know that means
we auctioned off for $500 and by the way
we still are auctioning it off for $500
you can write anything you want on my
neck Koopa and then it's to that we
missed there's two don't we missed
apologies to them we're gonna do it
today to Cairo Kitty and Chelsea we're
gonna write those right now but
apparently there was how many is that
that's like 1717 neck Fupa cats I looked
hard as hell and Justin capped it off
with I love come on my forehead and then
the next day it was just all like
blurred and it just looked like you were
you had black stuff all over you your
neck disease mm-hmm it's a nice change
from what how I usually look oh I'm
focusing on that black stuff on your
neck and not your disgusting body um
black light journal Alex's limited
edition Journal raised eight
and Rick and Morty skateboard deck raced
almost 7,000 goddamn boy Alex's flannel
6000 the dummy I'm just going over the
notable ones now but Donny dolls 5000
that's an old mean the voice message is
work we we auction off for $1,000 you
can get a custom voice message from
either us or Justin or Alex or anyone
yeah we're gonna you can still buy those
we're giving those out on Tuesday as
well we'll have them well close it on
Tuesday and start it will be their last
day for everything yeah and then if you
go down to the bottom if you go all the
way down to the bottom and I'm kind of
upset I don't force you guys Skippy's
belly button lint two hundred and thirty
six dollars I mean we valued this at a
minimum of twenty five hundred guys can
we please I feel bad for the guy can we
please get some donations for Skippy's
bellybutton lint and I give a special
shout out to teddy bear suplex who gave
25 for that he is 10% of the raffle yeah
you've got 10% of the raffle covered
there's a really good chance that you're
gonna be sniffing that on Tuesday unless
new competitors come out please guys
come on this is ridiculous
nobody 236 that's it give me a [ __ ]
break you don't know what's been covered
the champagne I know what down I'm just
gonna have to give it back to him at
this rate I'm just gonna have to give it
back to him just say I'll send you some
island instead because he has way too I
have a value on that and then one other
noteworthy one which is worth can you
know mentioning brats oh the games of
miracles hooked it up with a $1 donation
so shout out although wait wait wait dan
I think we oh nevermind I'm bet I've
misunderstood that I just want to yell
at you Dan
nevermind so anyway that's what's up all
those items are still available ela do
you want to write on my 10 mm or 1000
for the dining suit yeah I know
which is awareness someone ik Ben Ezra
Azara gave
hundred for that mm-hmm yeah that's all
that is ancient mean you got the Sharpie
yeah all right so before we begin let's
just let's pay our debts here
we forgot to neckloop us or we miss them
I think probably because there was
trouble with the website so my neck
football raised 8,500 bucks I'm English
who can't say that I'm using my food
save Texas for Chelsea yes and breast
milk breasts breasts is it breast or
breast Dan then this is breath Br all
right you like get to work one if that's
some kind of inside joke
oh that's just breast milk bye
yeah go ahead um so anyway thank you
everyone for donating I see going up now
god bless huh says we're the erotic
ILA's drawing on my Fupa now what are
you writing he can write something when
my dad gets here my dad's gonna be here
around 3:00 he said so I'll run a
special where you can have my dad write
something on my [ __ ] you can have my
dad draw swastika on my forehead so what
else we have to talk about here save
Texas HeLa it's up to you now okay don't
[ __ ] this up
do you like that a new fetish discovered
you guys thanks for that safe press this
is hard [ __ ] yeah mm-hmm all right get
the hell out of here EULA you take it
too long whatever what are you writing
I feel like this is taking too long
all right are you done okay okay here
you go guys this is thank you that's a
thousand bucks to charity
get the hell out of here damn close a
freaking door and I your [ __ ] together
in the intern stop [ __ ] around out
there in the internet you're not you're
not doing what you're supposed to be
they're the best I love them okay um so
let's move on so that is what that is
and thank you everyone who continues to
donate we are honestly in more need of
it now than ever before and what I want
to talk about more a little bit now is
hurricane Irma let me show you this look
at this tweet while dissented that's
really bad this is awful
what if I done let me see if I can do
something here oh my god this is awful
what have I done I just I just I
actually have an image instead of a link
that's like I'm like grandma
yeah alright let's get serious we're
getting serious here guys I don't know
how to get serious when I'm actually
just looking at a dock that's a zoomed
in 20 times but let's get serious right
you can zoom out well I want to show the
image oh can you find this to me Dan
just do me a favor the situation room
CNN sit room
QB hmm capisce okay all right all right
this is pretty indigent this is pretty
pretty rough stuff here okay there's
pretty rough stuff yeah how you doing
how you feeling talk to me well I manage
my life here I had a lot of fun writing
on your neck I'm looking forward to more
opportunities like that in the future
okay all right well you guys heard it
put in that mind the opportunity but if
you're trying to do like silly stuff for
charity cuz then there's no feeling bad
it's all good paternity like I can spray
Joey cells in the face with mace and
it's like yeah that was great man we're
all
happy about that so talking about
Hurricane Irma which is now the
strongest hurricane ever to come out of
the Atlantic Ocean and is now barreling
down on Florida here's some footage of
it rolling over st. Maarten here have a
look at this someone is recording this
[Music]
and this is about this is probably close
to 180 miles per hour when this is just
a metal fence that's being flattened
it's pretty much the apocalypse yeah
Jesus you can't even see anything
something just blows up something just
lights on fire in a hurricane to make it
more apocalyptic and it's just yeah I
mean the video cuts out um excuse the
the audio there but just to give you an
idea of what as actually we're dealing
with here I don't think yeah Dan got
that tweet thank you very much I don't
see it here's a tweet that that oh my
god here you go alright check this tweet
out this isn't the one Dan they kill me
it was for a split second I had a moving
on if you find it let me know but anyway
they tweeted out it's official no storm
on wreck what you can just read it it's
official no storm on record anywhere on
the globe has maintained winds
of 185 miles per hour or above for as
long as Omaha's that's crazy
and it's just tearing it up okay look at
this is another video of Irma that
really just freaking blew my mind my
fear let's see here this [ __ ]
[Music]
so the whole damn city is being blown
away trees are being uprooted and just
completely torn no that's how it ends
presumably with the end of civilization
I mean this this is serious stuff here
and yet another video there's these guys
um
hurricane hunters you know about these
guys you know oh yeah they're
meteorologists that have these special
and super powerful airplanes that can
fly through the eye of a hurricane and
that's how they get like how they
measured the speed and intensity and how
they decide that it's like a category 5
there's actually insane fleet of people
that fly through the eye of a hurricane
so here is footage of these lunatics
flying through the eye of Emma
[Music]
you can actually see when they break
through
right now it's just great it's crazy
because there must be pretty high and
there's just like debris everywhere
let's see okay look at this
[Music]
Carolee see it it's a brief there you go
here's the eye
crazy it's just like fine it's all good
it's all good here
yikes I can't believe they're just
flying through it so I find that I just
find that fascinating if I may say so
there's actually just a fleet of lunatic
meteorologists that fly through this
heart of these things fascinating mm-hmm
Shawn just said that his wife um lived
on that island oh yes a mark ten plus
years yeah what she her I wonder what
she's heard from getting a bunch of
pictures from her friends about what's
going on there what I heard in the news
is essentially these these islands
basically in the Caribbean are 95%
completely destroyed pretty much every
single structure on these islands was
flattened and completely ruined in the
path of this hurricane um here I've got
some photos here I don't know what is
going on I mean this is what it's three
hurricanes at the same time yeah and
there's another two of following up
behind it here basically if you're in
Florida you're just totally [ __ ] right
now here's a forecast from this yeah it
depends where you are but I mean if
you're in like South Florida where it's
gonna get hit the most you should be
definitely evacuating the governor is
giving emergency messages being like
this is not something you can write out
yeah you cannot sit in your house and
wait this out you will die 55 miles per
hour you can see the center of
circulation is different is also looking
at what they too many days we have a
hurricane watch in place so to kind of
break things down for you here a
hurricane warning
this is where we could see sustain it
was in anybody down here in South
Florida they do need to get out there's
no east or west you can go to the fishes
all has to start heading north and there
I read is catastrophic that's how they
how they categorize it so pretty much
the entire southern tip of Florida from
us to evacuations in Miami is just gonna
be catastrophic she's gonna be
underwater areas you see here he's gonna
have the system is going to continue to
quickly move but the rains going to it's
gonna hit like this weekend so we're
gonna know how bad it is pretty pretty
soon after but essentially the money
that we're raising here on tilt if I
link is below in the description it
should be relatively easy to find is
gonna help all these people it's gonna
help all them it's gonna help the people
who are don't have health insurance you
don't have access to clean medicine that
they need to survive this is money is
gonna directly go to saving people's
lives the people who need it the most
this website it's kind of got rich by
the way just want to put that out there
it's also great but it's yeah it's
pretty good not always running luckily
the money doesn't even go to them it
goes straight to the to their charity
yeah to the charity yeah
alright anyway um you know it's
important to to to acknowledge all this
stuff going out here in the world right
now I don't know look at this thing man
from the sky this is basically what's
happened in Arma as it passed over the
Caribbeans
I mean this is climate change man the
earth doesn't want us here anymore
another's earthquakes earthquakes Mexico
yes there's solar flares this is like
the beginning of a bad sci-fi movie
starring Bruce Willis this movie would
get like a 30% around tomato yet here we
are the main things that I can't stop
thinking about like all your stuff
you're hot every all gun even if you
have insurance it's yeah it's like a
personal stuff imagine your whole house
and everything you have in there is just
drowned and blown Oy mm-hmm
I mean my god how do you rebuild from
that must be amazing for an artist to
afterwards do a project where they go
and collect he wants to be there their
ruins you always got a good idea for
artists out there someone go do that
anyway look not not the most upbeat
charming thing but I think it's
important now that were deep into this
fundraising that we make one last push
to try to raise as much money as we can
for those people because yes well save
people's lives
gosh this was a great little story they
came out you know rush limbaugh is I
think so
he's a conservative talk radio character
and he went on this tirade about how
hurricane Irma is a liberal conspiracy
to sell bottled water what and this
happened after Houston was already
buried and you know 15 feet of water he
says he basically says that he doesn't
say he doesn't think the hurricane
exists but he thinks that there's like
hysteria over it that the liberal media
plays it up to further the agenda of
global warming and sell more bottles of
water
which I love that the conclusion is like
no it's a conspiracy to make global
warming seem real instead of like it's
[ __ ] real there's three of
record-breaking hurricanes that is
destroying our country it's a conspiracy
it's like the same explain it to the
people who lost their houses I did
just just hysteria well answer this EULA
did they sell more water you know well
you have to look at who is more like
who's gonna profit the most from this
right the water and it's obviously the
water bottle people they're killing it
maybe diamond water will make a comeback
time and water
let's get Diamond water on a discount
y'all and help those hurricane victims
out III listen I know we have some
conservative leaning people who listen
to this show
I don't think global warming is a
partisan issue at all I don't know how I
don't know why global warming has become
a partisan issue it's not it I don't
know why it's become this whole thing
about it's a Chinese hoax that it's
we're trying to I don't even get it
global warming is happening the earth is
getting hotter
there are freaking hurricanes being a
lob datas earth is throwing them at us
you know it's it's it's a real thing and
I mean the it causes more extreme
weather these droughts that we had in LA
for like six years and then I was like a
super rain in LA yeah it's more hey
you're not gonna have rain for seven
yeah now it's not gonna rain for another
twenty years I mean while everyone else
is flooding but it's just more extreme
weather patterns it makes everything
else more extreme I was listening to
this guy talking about global warming
some scientist and it's like according
to what this guy was saying without
human intervention the earth should
actually be cooling because a lot of
people say well the earth goes through
warming periods anyway so how am I
supposed to know that it's man-made and
just as on an it's on another cooling
period or warming period but it's
actually on a cooling period it should
be cooling but it's rising like a
percent degree every frickin year I mean
this [ __ ] is real I don't know why we're
having this debate that that's the one
thing that really furious me I don't
know how global global climate change
has become a partisan issue that's just
bizarre find that very bizarre I feel
like at this point like everyone it
seems like everyone is agreeing on it
but then you see all these well all the
scientists yeah they're even like other
countries like in India even China and
India are cutting their their coal usage
arse ramping up their green energies
China is more progressive now but like
if you're if you're someone who denies
climate change you're literally in the
only country that there's still debate
about that the rest of the world has
moved on and accepted it but we're still
here being like is this a is this a
conspiracy for Al Gore to make a couple
more bucks
yeah that's why China is building green
energies to make Al Gore money I don't
get it I don't understand it you have to
be so deep into this party politics [ __ ]
which I hate by the way but like to
actually think that there's no such
thing as global warming you're so deep
into party politics the Rush Limbaugh's
kovitch you that is a conspiracy to sell
more bottled water I wish that was true
I'm [ __ ] angry I'm pissed
you want some water here listen to this
[ __ ] you just completely dismantle my
whole argument Fick and what Swope
here's here's here's something put in
perspective do you think smoking is bad
for you nobody nobody disputes that yet
the same amount of scientists that say
smoking is bad for you say that global
warming is a
man-made phenomenon that is warming the
globe and changing our weather patterns
for the worse
same percentage capita of scientists are
saying that as saying smoking is bad for
you they're still scientists out there
the Satan smoking isn't bad for you yeah
there's some dads out there
some say that's that they never believed
the hype telling you smoke cancer from
smoking is just a conspiracy theory for
the big chemo big chemos racking in on
that cigarette money
it's just obscene and this god-blessed
great country we called america red
white and blue eagles swooped down and
[ __ ] you up that was horrifying
good you drove my point point home you
know yeah what the [ __ ] man and I'm
telling you if you don't believe me find
if you think I'm gonna i'm a liberal
duck because i believe in global climate
change like [ __ ] 95 percent of the
world five years some people lost
respect for you yeah they probably lost
all respect for me which is fine just
chill chill back put your feet up and
wait for the hurricanes to come get you
or the droughts
it's me was a hundred and seventeen
degrees in LA last week for five days in
a row and I feel is 117 but it was
pretty bad it's just you know you can't
what you say well I think it was a 120
that's when you come in you're supposed
to support me on this it was over 110
can we agree on that
I guess thank you come on ela don't let
the facts get in the way for this story
record-breaking Heat
I did buy so much bottled water that
week huh
maybe that's [ __ ] anyway
freaking angry Bank PS and that's not it
telling you the earth does not want us
on this planet anymore earthquake in
Mexico 8.1 that is massive massive
people are dying structures are falling
apart Alex and Dana we're in Mexico yeah
we're like dude are you guys dead
they're like now we're pretty far I was
like okay but they felt it
yeah from hecka far away and then here
that's not I mean this I can't blame the
earth on this one but there was just a
huge solar flare that's blasted right at
the flippin earth man look at this oh
they took the article down low cool
solar flare just get blasted straight
from the Sun hits the earth and it's
like destroying satellites shutting down
radios something's going on here it's a
bad sci-fi movie and I'm just waiting
for Bruce Wallace to get on a [ __ ]
spaceship and go drill meteor just I
don't know I feel like that would save
us I think it's gotta be Tom Cruise but
Tom Cruise whatever I don't know that
Tom Tom Cruise is pretty a list I'm not
sure he's jumped on any meteors anytime
soon I don't know the scripts I don't
know that this this script on this
adventures up to snuff but this is the
beginning of a horrible sci-fi movie
maybe like um gosh who would star in
this [ __ ] show like Jean Claude Claude
am he's Manning the spaceship to the
center of the earth the punch to punch
some like weather demon who's been
[ __ ] too many dudes and creating
hurricanes I mean I hear I'm talking
about conspiracies of water balls but I
don't hear him talking about gays making
hurricane machines
me and Justin touched on that last week
we figured out it's not a lot of
Christians say a lot of Christians some
people say that all this these horrible
unfortunate things are a result of gay
people having sex but Justin had a
really great idea that's not it's not
it is from gay people but it's not from
them having sex is if they actually have
invented technology to create hurricanes
and it's like some Illuminati thing they
do it's not related to sex at all but it
is the gays it's a new show we're
developing it's called the gays did it
anyway
probably so don't forget also don't
forget that there was the Burbank fires
my sweetie Kelly's on fire too beautiful
117 degrees outside city's on fire yeah
I said 117 maybe 120 next to the fire
hundred fifty the fire was so weird like
the day after we heard about it we were
going out in the evening to some
friend's birthday party and we took an
uber at night and while we're driving to
a party we drove by those hills and you
just see like heels red fire yeah that
was a trend I was so weird it's like
yeah we're just driving to a party and
his fire right there right I saw and
that was like three days after and we're
just driving by were like are there
hills still on fire yeah like okay dope
la in the summer I saw this really
amazing picture actually that truly
truly amazed me and I think you'll love
it too dare I say fascinated me
fascinating that was good you're getting
much better on that I found it really
fascinating look at this picture this is
a real [ __ ] picture there on a golf
course plane and there's a enormous
that's exactly how enormous fire going
on the mountainside this is real Dan
this is what I was feeling exactly these
people are just like watching a movie or
some [ __ ]
this doesn't even give a [ __ ] even
incredible right anyway
all right let's let's let's cheer it up
I've got all kinds of fun stuff planned
so keep those donations coming y'all
you can still get all kinds of good news
we're at 160,000 let's get it to 200 you
got down last enough there's more and
Fupa writings oh yeah any good any new
food
so the Eman is actually some really
positive news came out of that that
stream I'm actually really proud of of
us are proud of the team took a lot of
work to put that together and I'll even
congratulate Ian the intern he's been
doing an amazing job screening calls and
I'll even congratulate him as much as I
don't want to but every kind of you been
doing a really great job and planning
that and executing it and I mean I'm
really proud of the team we have here so
thank you all to all of you guys and so
this prank call clip got number two on
trending how about how about that [ __ ]
but yeah I thought we were blacklisted
but in this video was actually trending
like this [ __ ] went kind of viral yeah
we saw Vice writing about it I saw some
articles who's here there it got ripped
off on Facebook coffees yeah no I love
when people are like we're doing this
for charity and they'll rip it off and
not even put the link to charity it's
like you monster god anyway that was
that was pretty cool that was exciting
oh did we just get a five hundy what
else
Joey salads actually I wanted to call
Joey if you guys didn't know if you saw
last week's episode but we Joe is such a
legend he calls me when he heard about
our charity stream and it's like hey I
want to do something to help you guys
out how about I spray myself and the
face with mace and I'm like this is what
this show is all about and so we had
this idea that I wanted to he couldn't
do it in the building obviously so we
had this idea to stream it and watch it
on our
show live and actually just worked out
so good and the fact that it was Justin
Justin was the executioner was a
wonderful wonderful twist and I know he
was actually suffering quite a bit he
took that right in the eyes he had
mentioned that he intentionally opened
his eyes because he wanted it to be
legit yeah that was him writhing in pain
let me call him let's see how is he
doing you guys I mean he did it he did a
great thing for the for the nation for
the Fupa nation I want to make sure that
he's thanked for that
hey what up Joey you're on the air yeah
hold on one second [ __ ] sake every time
with him I'll just sit here quietly all
right hey how are you feeling dude I
feel great really energized I'm gonna do
it again
uh-huh then will you play that sound how
are you feeling in that moment was that
a genuine like regret I thought I was
gonna die I don't know I one point I
wasn't able to breathe and if you look
you can see me like panting did you see
the super slow-mo footage yes yeah yeah
there's some good screenshots that well
anyway I didn't realize how I didn't
realize how much I was yelling at Justin
I was reviewing the footage now I was
really I don't think anyone took it
personally but I love the idea of just
being angry I mean he just he just
sprayed you in the face like you wanted
right yeah did he go harder than you
thought he would cuz he did hold it down
for a good amount of time even though
like I tried footage there's like one
part I slightly open my eyes like a tiny
drop and then it just you got I guess is
that slow-mo front is gonna be updated
or uploaded somewhere it is up right now
play it I'll put it on after this call
yeah I noticed when Justin was spraying
you it was a good long sustained spray
like almost as if you were an attacker
and he was trying to thwart you yeah
right yeah I know he's always constantly
worried about that and I and I know when
you came back to the office you were I
know your eyes were seemed fine but
you're saying your skin hurt work wasn't
contacted I was all the milk in this
canteen solution on my eyes I neglected
my skin so all that upper spring seeps
into my skin is somehow I trimmed down
to my general region oh thanks my arms
were burning for the entire day after
and then yeah for like a day and a half
afterwards I was still like coughing up
from some type of spread like it was
filling my usual cavities not having
like cough like spicy coughs
start coughing well I just want to check
in make sure you're okay and once again
thank you you did a you did a great
thing man I think that was one of the
highlights of the whole show and I think
see that one speaks me over just yeah I
don't know I don't know that one I don't
want you to actually die that would that
might kill the bus I'll get a cop friend
of mine to do it if you go get a medic
if we can get a medic and a trained
professional yeah we could we could give
you a little bit of a zap yeah okay I
think are pretty low okay good it's like
like below temper
yeah yeah but as long as it's below 50 I
think we'll be fine
okay all right thanks again Joey you're
you're a champ and definitely the MVP of
the day so appreciate you buddy yeah all
right thank you talk to you bye-bye
I saw all these great comments about
that he was bathed and pepper and milk
and absolved of his sins I hadn't no man
that clip of him just dumping milk on
his face I don't know that that is a
thing like I know in your mouth baby but
I'm not sure the act of just dumping
gallons of milk on anyway
I was counting on him that he did the
research so it's Joey
he's a salad head he he took a little
ranch a little pepper
but it's good so turns out ranch and
pepper milk is a good salad dressing so
anyway thank you to the legend that is
known as the salad master um what else
is good-bye-ee are we doing any any
notable donations Dan nobody wants to
give us any money today oh they're
different money I'm having trouble
getting into the backend of tilta Pfizer
we're overloading them again tilt to 5mm
we passed 116 yeah we're past 160
actually listen Tulsa fine
I know they're like a charity
organization but at the same time you're
freaking gotta step it up dude mm-hmm
goddamn people our blood is on your
hands till to fire I don't want to say
you're killing people but the blood is
on your hands
I do feel bad for people if we're gonna
miss it while we're alive oh we're going
to know and you know and our big charity
stream it was down for like two or three
hours in the middle of our charity drive
and worse than that I was sobering up
from being blackout drunk and I'm
sitting here half brain-dead and I can't
even I don't even have a crutch
not anger about the donations I'm angry
what you did to me okay alright let's
let's let's get to the good old top of
the month top of the week um also there
was that screenshot if you check your
email me yeah then then some an article
where they refer to us as H - H - which
email Daniel yeah you know what email
him on yeah I sent it to the one I don't
see it oh there it is okay just came in
oh yeah this was pretty ridiculous
freaking this article is called during a
recent appearance on youtuber H - H -
production's podcast roiland prank
called Austin's church prayer line H - H
- I'm sorry
what who wrote this crap thank you why
don't you chew your own way out of here
with your H - H - how would you even
draw that conclusion it was actually a
Nerdist that posted that The Nerdist H -
H - Jesus I think they corrected it is
that just like a goof on us or this I
feel like you have to be an intentional
goof like it got him less than three
maybe it is well I just got slammed
sorry sorry the Nerdist freaking trigger
over here they're so angry all the time
now I'm just more angry mm-hmm alright
let's let's lighten it up let's get off
this let's watch some videos top of the
week classic here check this [ __ ] out
this was taken I don't know why this one
just gets me and tickles me in the best
way possible
dude and this is probably a modern-day
video dude is Anna library recording
some QT on his flip phone
[Laughter]
the guy's got a face like someone who
wouldn't be looking at adult females are
you would in a library quite okay yeah
he's got that face he's got a twist to
it yeah yikes there's sound in it too by
the way it's totally quiet but that is
the actual sound like you can hear him
stepping like that smile hey hey how are
you nice to see you oh man that guy's
got to work on his um guy's got to work
on his minimize timing so what was he
doing taking a picture of a picture from
there yes are you may have been filming
it it's a video the picture probably was
take a picture now yeah it was probably
a picture
he was like thinking it's Tom well I
thought it was a video cuz he's really
taking his time but I guess he was just
very serious about the art and
photography in that in a library so
shout out to that guy who was probably
off somewhere given having a nice old
fat said that to their library to that
sweet young lady shout out to a library
and shut up to the guy who just silently
walked up to him recorded him and then
silently walked away wonderful stuff
here guys
hey the world isn't all death and
destruction hmm you've got some other
people out here doing some interesting
stuff this one I just feel bad but it's
also a laugh this is taken from some
kind of kid show trivia show on BBC have
a look today is world geography
well geography you will decide in your
airs who's gonna go first who's gonna go
second and whoever's going first please
step up to the podium
[Music]
okay let's find out slow-mo after this
100 people 100 seconds to name as many
countries that end with two consonants
as they could countries that end with
two consonants Richard consonant you
know that is second on Val so pretty
much anything with land at the end it's
a bit of a trick question I'm gonna skip
through all this but anyway she he gets
to the first contestant in it are you
max volume turned up all the way and
it's still pretty quiet
let me check yes I am yes yes Paris
that's rough stuff I mean besides
obviously not being a country it doesn't
do that it also doesn't have two
consonants up in I feel bad for really
but the game show hosts really her
partner just looks horrible I'm really
really do boy really don't worry don't
worry don't worry do not worry about it
we can't go back this is life don't
worry hey I wouldn't be at all surprised
if several 100 scorers in this round and
B it's always tough getting on that
first podium so I'm sorry to put you
under that pressure sir Paris that's a
cute move on just let her stop living in
that moment I'm so sorry everyone else
is gonna [ __ ] this up I guarantee for a
number of reasons
I feel bad for that poor girl but it's a
laugh and it's a goof and it's most
definitely a booth I heard boof recently
I was a stray you didn't make that up no
I didn't make up boof I heard somebody
say it
boo still like it's a boof and I was
like wait that's not a word and I looked
it up and it's not a word
boof is not a word but somebody used it
with like almost certainty so now
boof is a work I kind of like it
what would bill mean if it was a word I
don't know I'll try to use it in this
part like a buffoon a booth
yeah boof like it was a boof
what does that mean like watching this
video was a booth all right okay here's
the joy salad slow-mo I love that oh
yeah Otis McDonald does it get sprayed
in the face all right Joey I love you
I'm not watching 15 minutes in your vlog
[Music]
somehow the music and the footage is
kind of miss mad music it's like a
cooking show
it's like jazzy jazzy and fresh as chili
dumps milk on his face and rides in pain
geez she's in Whiteface right now yeah
this is I feel like I'm supposed to feel
happy I'm in the oven cook him up add
milk and you got yourself a pepper salad
pepper milk salad what if Justin just
took that pepper spray game another
blast
[Music]
oh oh oh oh
Charlotte is ready all in the name of
charity taking off the shirt where we
are at one sixty one thousand let's keep
you still can't see Rewards back there
Dan let me try again let's see what til
two five 404 not found there Delta Phi
is absolutely poofing right now well I'm
sorry to the people who are donating we
will get you on Tuesday guaranteed it's
a bit of a booth it's just a bit of a
boob here today folks what else we got
here
okay it has been an hour so if you
wanted to do oh yeah we got a doors
thank our sponsors I'm sure yet here we
go
first of all thank you to our sponsor
the always gracious and supportive
Dollar Shave Club they've been with us
for a long time I appreciate them I love
these guys man let me tell you about
Dollar Shave Club their razors are off
the chain the only ones that don't give
me razor burn and there's nothing I hate
more they gettin burned by a razor it's
like you shave your neck and it's just
like totally flipped for a whole week
yeah and then by then you have hair
again and it's all itchy mm-hmm but I
don't know Dollar Shave Club we've got
these great razors they're just great
lots of blades um and they're doing a
basically they've got right now you can
get the shave butter the body wash what
well this is a new one one wipe Charlies
butt wipes what's that that's I'm
telling you that's real that's awful
right now it says here in your first box
you will receive their shave butter body
wash and one
charli's butt wipes and you well first
of all I didn't know they are including
butt wipes well let me tell you I don't
have to tell you about how much I love
wet ones always end with a wet one it'll
change your life
in fact ela not to be making a
competitor to Dollar Shave Club but I
think we should make our own brand of
wet ones because I'm passionate about
anyway back to it back you know back to
the point here for a limited type Dollar
Shave Club is basically giving their
[ __ ] away
showers oh this is their motto [ __ ]
shower shave starter kit for five
dollars that's pretty cute so that
that's the meme there for five dollars
this starter set features their
executive razor and three trial size
versions of their most powerful popular
products that help you stay fresh and
clean please don't forget one wipe
Charlies butt wipes I cannot endorse
these products and if I've never wiped
with their Wet Ones but I love Wet Ones
life-changing so [ __ ] shower shave kit
right here this exclusive offer is only
available at dollarshaveclub.com slash
h3 that's a Dollar Shave Club com / h3
to get that special offer listen guys
these guys have supported us they're the
best if you're in the market for some
[ __ ] shave and [ __ ] shower shave mmm
that's 3-step freshen up hit up
dollarshaveclub.com slash h3 thank you
to them and next we have hello fresh you
guys know about hello fresh they do this
great wonderful thing where they deliver
to your house all the ingredients for a
wonderful home-cooked meal and the
instructions on how to do it so you
don't have to buy anything they send you
fresh great ingredients recently me and
ela did it and I'm telling you it is
going to shock you how fun this is it's
really funny I thought that when I first
heard about this kind of services I
thought like it's gotta be a gimmick
absolutely my if I'm already ordering
food I'll just order it why do I need to
go to the grocery store yeah but it's
surprisingly really cool and fun because
it includes the recipes and sometimes
it's stuff that I would like never think
to make yeah and it has everything you
would need for it so you don't need to
like all of a sudden go buy a spice or
certs exactly fighting ger stuff like I
mean one of the challenges we have when
trying to cook meals is like I don't
know what to cook mm-hmm and every week
they have new recipes new fun exciting
recipes
no but seriously they're it's it's a lot
of fun I've been shocked I'm actually
kept my subscription live because they
sent this one to sample for the spot I'm
like dude this is this is freaking fun
I'm gonna keep doing it you're gonna sit
down with your loved ones your friends
your family and have a nice home-cooked
meal you don't have to worry about
getting you know ten pounds of cilantro
when you only need three Leafs yeah
we've all been there
[Music]
so you can receive $30 off your first
week of deliveries when you go to hell
afresh calm and use the offer code
Ethan 30 I'm not gonna lie it's a
strange coupon code okay hopefully that
will help you remember it it's my name
Ethan 30 that's how much you get off and
it's one word that's a good aloe fresh
and use the coupon code
Ethan 30 to receive $30 even is older
than 30 he's not just 30
he's owner thanks for making for being a
gist against Miele fresh Ethan 30 let's
see here what else is there to say I
mean it's great it's less than $10 per
meal so once again if you are looking
for a fun new eating experience they
deliver it to your door they've got like
ice
so can sit up there for hours and not go
bad it stays fresh I'm telling you guys
give it a shot you won't regret it
gosh okay go to boot that's a bit of a
booth
go to hello fresh calm and use coupon
code even 31 word link is in the
description give it a shot
thank you to our sponsors who I
appreciate and who keeps this show
slammin and thank you to you EULA mm-hmm
thanks to you illa thank you thank you
to ela and the h2 issue organization
that's me that's just me else other than
you for this is one of the other shirts
we have available at h3 h3 shop duck
yeah go to h3 h3 shop comm to get some
of these fresh hot threads fascinating
this is by far the most popular one and
I freaking love the design fascinating
oh it's so loud and does it have to be
so loud so this is this is just a sample
we got the final ones being screen
printed in it's gonna be vibrant it's
gonna be beautiful and let me tell you
what else it's gonna be fascinating
fascinating I found it really
fascinating fascinating I found it
really fast
sorry tone it down anyway so if you want
to support the show and get some cool
shirts head on over to h3 h3 shop calm
note about those those should go out and
about a week or like 10 days these we
haven't started production of them yet
which we're starting Monday so we'll get
those out to all you guys as soon as
possible thank you all so much and now
back to the podcast and to twitch
subscribers like you I love doing like a
PBS classic like interviewers like you
all right you know what I'm talking
about
I do but I just don't know if it's
working yeah yeah it's a bit of it's a
bit of a bill just Boop that one up
pretty badly
welcome back to the h3 podcast live
welcome back we are going to take some
calls from supporters like you we've got
a bunch of videos on deck we are raising
money we're at one hundred and sixty one
thousand three hundred and fifty two
dollars nice nobody else wants to write
on my neck listen you think like last
week I just went home and showered I
actually have a ton of errands to do
today after the show
no I'm gonna be like Home Depot with a
swastika on my forehead and you know
something we're not accepting so I think
I know this nothing about saying you
could humiliate me all day for me or
$500 Dan what are you doing Saros just
like a stamp to Ethan from George thanks
thanks man we got water listen I told
dance specifically I said I know we're
in the pocket of big water we're in the
pocket of big bottled water don't bring
it on when I'm talking and this show
about global warming it's a total
conspiracy and he completely just blew
my cover that is fired you're fired 10
get out when we're done with the show
[Laughter]
I'm pissed
George Soros is funding my bottled water
habits mm-hmm all right guys let's take
some calls
let's see what's good we have got
epochal X who is now live hello
apocalypse talk to me baby what's good
bye I'm good man how are you so I wanted
to know what's the what's the hardest
thing about doing the live show and is
it a big change of pace from from doing
YouTube videos oh that's a great
question Thank You Man appreciate you
yes the answer is a big yes
Wow the live shows is rough well you do
it I guess the most obvious difference
is when you filming videos for YouTube
you get the luxury of editing right I
mean usually we'll film for like an hour
and
down to ten minutes and I've always said
I'm not that funny it's just the editing
and I truly think one of my best
qualities as a video maker is my editing
ability I think I'm a good editor so
it's like it's a completely different
skill to come on here live and just know
that it's all going up and there's you
know and it's just it's so much more me
yeah and you're so much more vulnerable
to people's judgement because you always
see comments like oh you always talking
over the guest or you're so ignorant and
[ __ ] like that because you're just
talking you're off-the-cuff you just
having a conversation you're chilling
with people when you hang out with
people you talk over each other a lot
you know
and it's just a completely different
skill set I think that's one of the
reasons why it excites me too is because
I feel like we've gotten pretty good at
making videos on YouTube by now and this
is just a completely different it's a
completely different field we're
learning to run a show we're learning to
present ourselves live it's a it's a
whole new terrain here so it's horrible
but it's exciting because it's different
and it's weird like I feel like people
are noticing every little thing about it
it's weird like one for two or three
hours you don't think about what you do
and it's just funny to see like people
notice you know you like little habits
or write weird things that you do I have
trouble watching myself on the podcast I
can't watch I can't I don't watch it
usually on YouTube I have no problem
watching myself back but on the podcast
it's like oh my god my Tourette's is
like so obvious and you know and when
you're sitting with somebody and you end
up talking over them in your mind it
feels like a conversation but in the
vaad you're just like you [ __ ] idiot
just shut up you know I mean sometimes
I'll watch myself and just be like shut
up stop talking but you don't think
about it that way in your head yeah and
short it's made me hate myself quite a
bit more
all right um we have got on deck
with us today Chris man Freddy what's
good doggy
yo what's up man hey how are you I'm
doing good so uh listen my question is
if you could live in any video game
movie or TV universe what would it be
all right thanks dude appreciate it
I'll see your my spirit in Oh lady
appreciate that sounds like a fish I'm
into that um okay I cut him out spirit
animal and I started getting or I was
like half chubs already and I feel like
I just took a Viagra what was the
question
any movie TV show or a game do you want
to live in right I would love to live in
oh man feel like every game is just like
dystopian nightmare I would want to be
in Mario Sunshine what about you you can
I mean can I be a shape and live in
Tetris yeah the best shade that's a cute
that everybody loves them then why do
you uh that's why you're so beloved by
everybody actually I do have a real
answer Star Trek I love the Star Trek
writers it's a utopian world money
doesn't exist anymore
robots yeah I've taken over all the
tasks everybody has a basic universal
income and they pursue themselves to the
Arts Star Trek thanks for the question
all right what else we get here let's
move it harm its show um this video gave
me a giggle
shoenice you guys all know shoenice he's
got this [ __ ] he's got this raging
hate boner for us yeah we have a whole
story with him I don't remember what
happened like maybe you should yeah give
people versed happen when we made it
a video about feeding the homeless
because that was a huge fad with
pranksters and shoenice had a video
where he was feeding the homeless and
it's just hilarious to include shoenice
in some way and he has this one where he
buys like a Big Mac for a homeless
person or is a whopper and I wasn't
really even making fun of him I just
like look shoenice is handing out
whoppers guys uh and ever since then
he's just been obsessed with us and I
was thinking about having him on the
podcast because he's just such a wild
Christ such a lunatic getting to come in
here to eat some deodorant or something
and he was like I'll be in LA in a
couple of weeks or next month or it was
very open-ended I was like okay well
I'll let you know and I and we were just
like man I don't know cuz he started
talking about like weird anti-semitic he
was like going on a really weird kick
and I'm pretty sure he's drunk all the
time
and we're like I don't want him Ida my
biggest concern was I don't want him in
this office not only because I'm afraid
he's gonna try to kill somebody but I
also don't trust him with the address I
think he would like posted on Twitter
immediately just out of a drunk
vengeance and so he ever since like we
never got back to him he's been on this
like absolute ramp east he gets drunk
he's done this about 20 times makes this
like rambling anti-semitic ramble and
then he erases it when he Sobers up this
is this one's called shoenice
anti-semitic rant attacking ethan ela
from h3 that wasn't his title his was
probably something like Ethan's a dirty
Jew from a Chester yeah but these are
pretty entertaining and I'll tell you
what but it's so funny all that happened
was that we discussed maybe doing a
collab or podcast I don't even remember
something right it was just in an email
and then we just didn't we just never
followed up like that and since then he
just just hates us like that tweets and
videos and he called you like us yes
this gang whatever
and go back to Israel classic stuff yeah
so I'm kind of into like shoenice hate
videos and it's it's so surreal to be in
this because we used to watch his videos
yeah
like years ago him slamming Barza
deodorant even he's drinking paint with
light in it which may you know explain
his descent into madness all the led
but other than that it's just it's great
I mean it's funny it's a it's a really
been a hero's journey for us from
watching shoenice blend a shoe and eat
the scraps to being on the receiving end
of a anti-semitic rant that's a really
magical I mean we really I almost want a
high-five so without further ado let's
enjoy little punk-ass [ __ ]
millionaires between their YouTube
accounts and come on and make a video
like Ethan's giving filthy Frank some
dollars this video was uploaded like a
couple of days ago and he's talking
about the homeless one wish we made like
two years ago and then he's gonna rip on
me Ethan in ela what is it ela [ __ ]
Bigfoot whatever you guys are gonna sit
there and rip on the smaller youtubers
feeding the homeless Ethan go [ __ ]
yourself seriously eight 3x3 is
overrated and he got a bunch of robot
[ __ ] people watching you [ __ ] your
wife she looks like why are you tequila
lady's obsessed with the yeah with
insulting you specifically and here's
the best insult girl 4:20 she looks like
custard over 4 to 1
for real suck my dick dude 3 the
homeless and she [ __ ] Jew I
love the twist anti-semitic at the end I
can held it down to the very end and
then it's like feed the homeless you a
cheap [ __ ] Jew love it yeah
it's gossip do you look like custom
group 4:20 maybe we have like long hair
and let me get them you I mean maybe
he's really funny I mean that's a great
as a really great insult Wow actually
battalion customer oh yeah like huh does
that mean you look like metalli we all
have to ask you nice about this I think
he would be an interesting podcast guest
but I would want like legit security I
would want him patted down before he
entered and I probably caught ya
handcuffed well have to restrain him
it'll be like a scene out of Silence of
the Lambs where he's just sitting in a
chair will have to muzzle and put a mask
on him it'll be fun he was saying that
he's live on YouTube right now was he
watching mm-hmm
let's who he's talking about Shh
shoenice why YouTube let's see let's get
deep into this guy's these shoenice
eating a cactus oh yeah he's live screw
reddit you can't donate YouTube doesn't
allow that smoke there's a modern orange
I don't know somebody that moderate [ __ ]
and if you start getting stoned they cut
off the donation but at the bottom we've
all been there yeah we've all been there
Thanks all right we've all been there
you know when you're doing a live stream
and you get two stones so they turn off
the donations we've all been there
hey yeah alright here's another story a
little [ __ ] weird one man this one
creeps me out kind of look I know this
one's about animal cruelty and I know
I'm a meat-eater I eat a lot of meat so
I on one hand need to acknowledge the
irony of me complaining about animal
abuse but this [ __ ] just really
surprised me they have genetically
modified foxes there's this one here or
this one Fox called a blue fox or
something and they've actually modified
its genes to grow freakish amounts of
fur all like like you would do it seems
so unethical like you would do to like
um a corn a piece of corn or something
to give it more yield they're doing the
same thing to living animals me as I
guess they do it to chickens and cows to
like it's it's really and so they they
make their first so freakishly large
that they can't even move they have
chronic pain look at these poor guys
Mandy so so how does it happen
someone's brain like thought of this
it's basically like dr. evil and really
good yeah I'm ruined
yeah oh damn that wolf has beautiful
skin let me make it completely immobile
and have and live in full agony until
it's put to death and skinned alive but
okay and if you see that jacket and you
know that that's what it took to make it
do you still want that jacket I think
the real thing is people don't want to
know how it's made
yeah I'll tell you I don't want to know
how my meat is processed because I
wouldn't I want it's hot it's tough I'm
very conflicted on the whole animals
thing because I on one hand am admiring
people who are vegetarians for the
purpose of preventing animal cruelty but
I I like eating me it's a good source of
of nutrition I'm just really hoping for
a day when it becomes more
cost-effective to grow it in a
laboratory I used to be a vegetarian
until Ethan ruined me
I [ __ ] up and [ __ ] up the world now
sheets me because I know you're too damn
skinny not a meat person you go through
waves yeah she still won't eat bacon
she's a good Jew she's not she's not in
her blood to bake I just don't like it
it's not about I'm telling you it's
gotta be because everybody loves bacon
it's very unusual to not like bacon and
frankly it's on American and I'm pretty
sure when you go to convert your green
card to a full bloating citizenship
they're gonna say eat this bacon and
rate it on one to ten and if you give
anything below 7 they may not grant you
that citizenship card I'm not saying
that okay let's open up they are he
loves you when you give him attention
now you're sure you can he's a pretty
talented now we're better than fine
and for those reasons I'm out sorry this
is so right all right let me say let me
say no it's not too late let me talk to
you straight to you shoenice okay it's
too late for me I'm going back to Israel
go back to Israel you got to her you did
this this is straight to you nice
we didn't really make fun of you on that
yeah I just included you for texture we
even said that it was the center of
YouTube and we called you the moral
center of you we said when shoe night's
is the moral center of YouTube is doing
altruistic acts of handing out whoppers
then you know that shit's a low off
kilter we were nice
I wanted to collab I wanted to have you
on the podcast and hang out with you but
you start acting like a lunatic you
scare me
you scare Allah not me but I'm saying
you're just a little unhinged dude like
I like you and I think you'd be an
interesting guest on the podcast but
it's like one minute you love us and
then the other minute it's you know I
wish you were in the World Trade Centers
when they collapsed I wish you didn't
get the memo from George Soros about the
bottled water anyway let's see what else
he's talking about I can't I can't look
away
anyway he's interesting he's
entertaining she may I call you shoot
mr. Shue more nice the shoe is good more
nice that's all I'm saying okay so
anyway the the we were talking about
these these mutant foxes
so these foxes are grown in laboratories
and cages and their and their fur
reportedly is being used by the top
fashion companies in the world like I I
can't say specifically who but basically
all the big expensive fashion lines are
harvesting fur from these beautiful
animals and just putting them on coats I
don't get fur anyway I mean I don't know
if I can see that because it like I like
I get leather how often do you get
better one pair but I have like leather
shoes right so I just don't know where's
the moral
where I can be like oh I don't like this
but I'll wear leather shoes I think it
is different but even even if you tell
me that like my purse is fake leather I
wouldn't mind it so I know I don't know
why people want to go that far
cuz you have all kinds of fur but this
is obviously like you mean fake fur yeah
this fake there's I mean the fascia is
almost indistinguishable yeah at this
point which is why I feel like you need
to go like seek this cuz you would pay
for it you pay a lot yeah
these jackets they use their fur I'm
talking tens of thousands of dollars you
pay for it you lose right but out
nothing I guess with me it's like I eat
beef so using leather is kind of the
same things like you're eating the cow
might as well use the rest of it do you
want to go vegetarian no I mean I would
like the idea I would if you do somehow
I feel like if I went vegetarian I'd be
even fatter
no you wouldn't I would just be a
monster I do I do like the idea of going
your vegetarian I always have I just
don't know I have the strength to UM to
do it anyway I couldn't go vegan vegan
is I don't Deacon's too far
cuz then I'll really have nothing to eat
and that's all like cheese and like eggs
no I think veganism is too far you can
you can peacefully have a symbiotic
relationship with animals like you can
harvest honey without harming because
you can harvest eggs without harming
chickens like you know there's good
sustainable ways to do it without cause
suffering to the animals I think
veganism is too far what else don't they
eat I mean you can you can get milk from
cows in a way that they're happy with
with that you know that they're not
suffering so I don't know I think that's
the little too far about any what the
[ __ ] do I know
it's just my thoughts here check this
video up this guy put this thing
together was uh really really good
in celebration of h3 is a legal victory
for fair use this guy is in deep with
the meme because he's the unoriginal is
from our and roll from long ago you
added this to the playlist right and
this guy every meme
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good what's his name how people go can
you post a link to this dude's name is
Dalton Anderson on YouTube Dalton this
is so good
head him up Dalton I just sucked a yeah
by EE yeah that was really really a lot
of fun there's another one somebody made
another Pharaoh made two dude he went
all out I feel like I'm not worthy yeah
I'm not good enough so weren't that man
that was really awesome Dalton yeah cool
ass [ __ ] but you should call in oh yeah
can we get Dalton on the phone dad
Edie someone reach out to him I'll be em
call him right away
let's get him right on the phone I hear
being ironic den and I'm gonna fight
your dad a deal after that should not in
your job description can't fire you
until then cuz I need you being ironic
is not in the job description
look over your jobs do you see irony two
strikes
there's no irony giving you in ten
minutes to get up on the phone okay okay
fair enough
Ian but now your ex is on the line
you're an intern you're expendable you
get as many of those as we need great
great guys I love them both but don't
cross me oops
all kinds of cables here ank you there's
this another one here this really great
family but I think me and heal are gonna
do a reaction to it on her main channel
so i'ma hold off till now but it's
really cool yeah I'm talking hehe now is
it great yeah it's powerful stuff I'm
not worthy man
not worthy what else this one this is
probably one of my all-time favorite
cringe videos I know you said you didn't
really I feel it's not my favorite I
don't know for me this one really is
just what it's all about
well let me break it down for you you
look as I feel like you must be missing
something
[Music]
absolute bonafide hit by the way how was
our fundraiser done where you guys that
or the flip you had won almost 160 so it
will not have access to anything Dan
I'll check again right now see if
they've fixed their sheet all right let
me know
meanwhile I'm gonna watch this let me
break this down for you good you need
someone to explain why this is so great
okay so this dude is scheming on
proposing to his girlfriend right now
okay yeah mom is going over there
completely face-plants yeah I see you
laughing okay no okay so she completely
phase notes here do you see into that
again I like they've got a great enjoy
it not even laugh you're just hurting
yeah your purest and MacPhail mm plug
stealing videos from all Crescent okay
faceplant now watch this that's the
laughs here comes the crap okay nobody's
helping her nobody's helping mom and
she's laughing she looks seriously
injured now watch this
gets down on his knees as Mama's
face-planted writhing in pain and pops
the question will you marry me now is
the time he thought to himself now he's
like I got a plan and I'm sticking to it
yeah no matter what happens in between
what are you doing mom get up mom
your daughter's do get your face into
the sin stop pretending to be her mom
like an angry at her and then this guy's
actually angry you're telling me this
isn't like I know you're laughing
daddy's getting angry then mom
face-planted and this idiot proposed
while she's facing the sand that's why
we're here hope it helps
I chrome the home 160 mm guys come on
people need you better proposal put it
out which is true but I didn't fulfill
mine and mine went to plan okay what
then what do you what do you say me damn
Oh for [ __ ] sake tilta phi is down and
they're back end
they are literally have blood on their
hands that's not fair and I show you
something as a little it makes me a
little angry about this one where did it
pass 162 oh thank you guys thank all you
guys so much thank you everyone for
supporting this and so beautiful great
khans tell me is this something I should
and this is just my ego okay it doesn't
mean anything but it's a little
triggering here what then we're not in
popular campaigns
oh wait we are I guess it's because it's
live right now but I know we're but did
they remove the that won't [ __ ] me here
you go
here here umm okay [ __ ] me oh right my
bad they changed it now I made a fool of
me
so they had like a list of most popular
wish fundraising and on the top part was
like ones with 60 bucks and we're at the
bottom and it's like rate and whatever
yeah I'll tell you what it is they did
update the website yeah nobody's been
working on the damn website they
actually should take more money they
take 5% I read that that's how they pay
for this website apparently I don't know
where that's money going but it's not
the hosting and now I'm angry before you
thought I was angry now I'm ready to
fight you nice I'd love to get a giant
q-tip and just go on I'm almost you nice
chug a bottle oh we're at 162 was that
what I said and finally you know there's
something I didn't want to talk about
hey we get I noticed that there's a lot
of split and opinions about some of the
videos that we choose to react to for
example our most recent one about
digital blackface and we did the whole
white face meme and I get a lot of
emails and I see a lot of comments and I
know that videos like that make like I
don't even want to say social justice
warriors but progressive left people
makes them uncomfortable and makes them
unhappy it makes them feel like I'm not
one of them and they get concerned that
when I make videos making fun of social
Jose
whereas that I'm in bowling in the
alt-right
and conservative movements and they
think they start to look at me like I'm
the enemy right mm-hmm and they and
people I think they wonder why and they
don't know where I stand and I want to
say I actually want to talk about that
publicly because I find it really
annoying I have said this many times
I've always identified myself as a very
progressive person socially economically
I'm very progressive person and I have
always been my whole life in college
Barack Obama served two turns I'm a fan
of Obama I voted for him both both terms
okay and up until recently like I think
it started happening basically when I
finished college there's this new
movement on the left that is completely
tearing my political identity apart
and the country's you know it's one
thing to make fun of like who what am I
gonna make fun of on the right Nazis
running people over that's not funny
it's horrifying it's obvious I don't
need to go make a video be like this
Nazi ran over people don't [ __ ] them
there's nothing interesting or funny
about that it's awful there are horrible
people right or you know people marching
around with Nazi flags like and I'm not
trying to compare that which is
objectively awful to some some some like
cult of outraged people but first of all
it's redundant extremes
yeah I guess of the two sides I mean one
is worse than the other let me say that
not I don't think oh I'll try it are
Nazis but like that's like this all
right are Nazis I think but I'm not all
conservatives all are right or well
anyway whatever all right or like white
white nationalist that's the movement
that he's kind of like they kind of took
over there though I don't think all of
them wanted to be I think white
nationally I think the problem is that
in the media they started using this
term all right as this wide sweeping
term to say anyone who leans
conservative and
them I think the real alt-right movement
is a white national movement and there's
not that many actual people in it but
you look at this concern me say oh
they're all right it's the same thing
you know on the left it happens your
[ __ ] your lib [ __ ] or whatever you know
it's like you have this sweeping
generalization that just dismisses
everybody as problematic your auntie feh
mm-hmm right and so on but on the left
you have or your social justice where
that social justice warrior is basically
the equivalent of all right on both
sides used to dismiss people you
disagree with and so I find first of all
social justice warriors or progressives
I don't even know how super progressive
left extreme left extreme left yeah like
anti-free speech left seems to be a
oxymoron but they are first of all way
more ridiculous in like just what they
say and think is just hilarious to make
fun of okay right on the surface value
it's ridiculous but more than that I
find it I take it personal because these
are the people that I'm supposed to be
identifying what these are my political
allies and they're they're kind of
alienating me they're ripping my
political home away from me with these
ridiculous garbage digital blackface and
man spreading and all this [ __ ] mess
planing mansplaining internalized
oppression all this [ __ ] xarna it's like
you are dealing in amazing the whole
freakin left and you're empowering the
people that I really actually do eight
which is the alt right an actual Nazis
so like there's nothing interesting to
say about them their shitty Nazis
they're white supremacist I don't
believe in that [ __ ]
obviously I hate it think it's garbage
it's unamerican but you guys are
empowering them and you're alienating me
from my own home and even beyond that
you're just hilarious
you're a much funnier you're much easier
and funnier to and
it's funny so I just want to say that
publicly for once because I seen a lot
of [ __ ] like this and they say trade
your empowering you know white
nationalist people wondering are you
white nationalist enough obviously not I
they hate me more than anyone but
[ __ ] Jew even though I'm a completely
secular I don't even believe I'm out
atheist pretty much a agnostic
essentially throwing through us go white
a white nationalist if I'm white and
they'll say hell no yet [ __ ] Jew if
you ask the social justice worry if I'm
a minority they'll say absolutely not
your privilege as it gets your Jew I
mean everybody hates me I have got no
[ __ ] allies anywhere guaranteed and
I've got arthritis anyway so that's my
that's my two cents on that I just want
to say that publicly for the record
mm-hmm the next time somebody has some
[ __ ] to say about that so that's pretty
much our show today
I do wanna announce that on Wednesday
next week I'm going to Israel for two
weeks
mm-hmm so Ethan is gonna be on his own
do it I am freaking and it's the first
time I think then we're gonna be
separated for two weeks I don't know
it's light and separated even for a day
since we started like you moved to
Israel before me yeah that was it know
that but beyond that I don't think
mm-hmm even a day so please take care of
Ethan yikes don't be too mean I'm scared
do you want a wife um I'll stage shortly
cuz it's I don't know maybe not do you
want me to say yeah
Ellis dad was diagnosed with lung cancer
and it seems like well anyway
she's just going home to spend some time
with her family it's rough I mean I just
want to be upfront and talk about it so
you guys know what's going on so she's
just going for two weeks spend some time
with your family I'm gonna come stay
home and hold down the fort and that's
pretty much it nice no tension and
there's yeah it's you know it's it's
rough out there man
there's always anyway send some nice
thoughts to her and her dad and I'll
just be sitting here when's your last
day on Tuesday so Tuesday we'll be
sharing and Friday Tuesday and then
another Friday I'll be here solo
probably I'll cancel over I guess and
I'll just for about an hour or two just
stare like this at the camera just the
sneak preview if you guys thinking of
tuning in so anyway thank you guys for
watching thank you all you guys for your
amazing generosity we're at a hundred
and sixty two thousand dollars I'm sorry
if anyone bought a neck Fupa signing we
won't honor those on Tuesday till 2phi
apparently wants people to die there
till the pie I suggest hiring one
employee just one and thank you also our
stream ended abruptly last week but I
wanted to thank Justin roiland
and Alex Hirsch and Dana Terrance Terry
how do you say Terence Terrace like a
balcony and of course Joey salads for
their help and their contributions and
everything I'm super proud of the
community and I thank you guys so much
for helping us support all this month
raise all this money and you can still
enter the raffles if you're listening
this it'll be open till next week so
that's it for this week guys and we
shall see you
on Tuesday appreciate you and Tata
[Music]